se sont rendus sur place à ménétréol sur
sauldre un chantier d'automne c'est un
geste citoyen pour la nature un chantier
pour mieux découvrir les systèmes
naturels existantes aujourd'hui la
tourbière
première étape la réalisation d'une
plaque à serpents on va poser salle en
fait ce choix c'est un endroit qui est
pas mal ici parce que c'est plat idéal
pour observer les serpents ça leur sert
de refuge
ils viennent s'y mettre il aime bien s'y
mettre parce que c'est noir
ça prend la chaleur et ils ont besoin
d'avoir de la chaleur pendant pendant
pendant la journée
ils peuvent aussi si jamais il fait trop
chaud allez un peu du côté ombre des
serpents des lézards des insectes mais
aussi des espèces végétales la tourbière
et d'ailleurs constitué de plus d'un
mètre 70 de seine c'est de la mousse qui
accumulent de l'eau pendant pendant
toute sa vie qui s'est vraiment une
éponge
c'est la base de la tourbière en fait et
en fait comme elle pousse dans un
endroit où l'eau est acide et bien il
n'y a pas de micro organismes pour la
décomposer ce qui fait qu'elles
s'accumulent
d'année en année c'est tumulus accumulé
celles cumulées c'est ça qu'on appelle
la tourbe cette année la tourbière a
souffert de la sécheresse et pourtant si
l'on écrase la mousse on est vite
surpris
le but du chantier de comprendre le
fonctionnement de la nature mais aussi
de la préserver des plantes invasives
ici le raisin d'amérique l'or va donc
agir on va pas de couper parce que si on
le coupe ça va beaucoup repoussée donc
il va falloir s'amuser à l'est la
rachète donc l'importance et les petites
graines qu'on voit là les petites
graines noix là ça on va les enlever
déjà pour pas qu'elle tombe par tous les
mettre dans un sac et ramener tout avec
nous alors le week-end prochain si vous
avez envie venez voir la tourbière des
landes à ménétrol sur sauldre mais ne
faites pas comme moi prenez votre
imperméable